why hello there
all you racists all you bigots all you
homophobes all you transphobes all you
xenophobes and you good old-fashioned
americans
this is the reuben report direct message
for january
26 2021
and we're going an hour early today it's
10 a.m pacific
because believe it or not people i'm
getting on a plane
and i'm going to travel to the free
state of texas
that's right i'll be in dallas for the
next couple days shooting
roughly 800 000 shows with the fine
people of the blaze doing a bunch
of stuff with glenn beck and ali stuckey
and a couple other people
and uh we'll be shooting our show from
there as well and i'll be doing some fox
hits and a bunch of other stuff
and according to the voice in my ear i'm
going to go
out and eat dinner with friends while
i'm there and
possibly go shopping and
maybe even take a walk in the park
anything's possible in texas
uh ironically i am leaving tomorrow uh
well i'm leaving today so i'll be there
tomorrow friday is when
california partially reopens so i will
not be here
as we partially reopen and people who've
been trapped in the dark
in dungeons who haven't seen sunlight
they gonna you know try to open the door
and come outside and it's gonna burn
their eyes and burn their skin
make them look like zombies thus you
know the zombie apocalypse that i've
been predicting
for a long time will happen uh all right
we got a bunch of stuff that i want to
get
to today a bunch of great stories uh
before anything though
my cracked youtube people have been
telling me that a lot of you have not
been seeing our videos
in your feed can you believe that is it
possible that youtube might be
manipulating
the algorithm might not be showing
videos that you want to see and might be
pushing you to other things to mess with
your mind
i don't know call me a conspiracy
theorist right uh if you are not
subscribed or even if you think you're
subscribed just make sure that you are
subscribed
just click that notification bell and
then once you click the bell you can
actually
uh you can filter it so that you can see
more of our videos make sure you see all
of them etc etc
i know a lot of people click it and then
it gets unclicked and the whole freaking
thing
yada yada and if you want to actually
ensure that you see all of our stuff
without any algorithmic manipulation or
anything else of course you can go to
reubenreport.locals.com and it's all ad
free and before we get to the show i
want to talk to you
fine people about built bar not bill
barr
a fine man i want to talk to you about
built
bar the protein bar it's a new year and
if you're looking for a new protein bar
i've got just the brand for you guys
built bar
is the secret to keeping both of your
new year's resolutions eating
healthier food okay eat tastier food too
that's two things
billbar are low calorie low sugar high
protein high fiber great for the keto
diet
i can actually lose or maintain weight
while indulging in a yummy treat
healthy has never been this delicious
built bars taste like candy and come in
18 amazing flavors including caramel
brownie and peanut butter
i've got coconut almond right here bill
bars are covered in 100 chocolate
including both nut
and nut-free flavors and are soft and
easy to chew after the holidays we still
want to indulge but we also need to shed
those additional pounds which is why
built bars are the perfect alternative
to pie
for the health-conscious guy each bar
contains only
to 160 calories 60 16
to 20 grams of protein and three to five
net carbs don't give up on your
resolution billbar is the answer go to
billbar.com and use promo code ruben to
get 20 off your next order use promo
code ruben to get 20
off at builtbar.com
and now back to dave rubin hello
all right let's talk about this chuck
schumer fella because he was on msnbc
with uh journalist rachel maddow
and she uh was asking him about some of
the things that joe biden could
potentially do
and he wants joe to use emergency powers
which as we'll get to in a moment that
reminded me
of something but let's take a look
describe to me new senate majority
leader chuck schumer's
main legislative priorities obviously we
have some things that are not
legislative technically the impeachment
of the president the
president's the new president's cabinet
um oh
can i say one other thing on cloud
please
i think it might be a good idea for
president biden to call a climate
emergency
why because then he can it relates to
what you're saying then he can do many
many things
under the emergency powers of the
president that wouldn't have to go
through
that he could do without legislation now
trump used this emergency for a stupid
wall which wasn't an emergency
but if there ever was an emergency
climate is one so i would
suggest that they explore
looking at climate as an emergency which
would give them more flexibility after
all it's a crisis
so a senator using emergency
powers where have we heard that before
misa proposed
misa proposed that the senate give
immediately
emergency powers to the supreme
court yes that was me
okay we couldn't play the video because
they've got all this copyright nonsense
that was my
jar jar binks can we put that image up
again i want to do that one more time i
felt good about that i'm gonna clear my
throat
misa proposed that the senate give
immediately
emergency powers to the supreme
court yeah play the original clip if you
can find the clip and then play my
version of that that is pretty spot on
jar jar binks for a guy that hasn't done
you know binks impression in about 10
years uh yes
you know the reason that i wanted to
play or show you that meme and do my
silly little voice there
is the idea that we're going to
constantly go from one crisis to another
we've had a covid crisis we'll have
economic crisis
we have a climate crisis is the world's
going to explode in 12 years and what
should we do along the way
we should give the people in charge of
us
in charge who have all the power we
should give them more power because only
if they had more power they could do
more for us even though they're a bunch
of incompetent buffoons
that's what senator palpatine knew and
uh
that's what jar jar binks gave him and
jar jar binks
is basically well i would say chuck
schumer is the jar jar banks of the
senate
now because he's trying to give him more
power and then we were looking at the
clip they kind of look similar
in a way look at these two binks schumer
schumer
binks they they look there's a similar
there's a the front of the face
uh if we could have had chuck with his
mouth open i think you would have seen a
little bit more of that the beady eyes
it's all it's all there anyway guys this
constant idea
that we need to give these people more
power that they have to do more for us
and that they can solve
anything you know the irony we're going
to show you a clip in just a second of
biden talking about the the roll out of
the cove thing
vaccination which he said he was going
to take care of and trump was a buffoon
and blah blah
and now he's basically saying he can't
do it um they can't do anything right
like what does the government do well
what
problem would you have in life that you
would say i
sure do want the government's help right
but ronald reagan has a great quote that
i'm going to slightly butcher something
like there's no problem that the
government creates that the government
can't make worse
i mean that really is the idea here but
we're going to give him emergency power
so he can solve the climate i mean it's
just completely idiotic we've got a
couple other quotes here this first room
from bloomberg as to what he could do uh
declaring a climate emergency could
unlock new powers for biden including
the ability to redirect funding for
clean energy projects shut down crude
oil exports suspend offshore drilling
and curtail the movement of fossil fuels
on pipelines trains and ships it could
unlock
new powers for biden including forced
lightning
if i'm not mistaken which if he uses too
much of could uh
you know completely uh melt his face and
then he would end up looking like
palpatine
you see what i'm doing here we'll do one
more from the new york times uh going
back to normal now means returning to a
course that will destabilize the
conditions for all human life
everywhere on earth we don't see normal
again we won't see normal again in our
lifetimes our parents and grandparents
burned
normal up in their american-built cars
with their american lifestyles
and their american refrigerators and
american dreams
um can one of you make a bleep sound
and i'm not gonna do it i'm not gonna do
it if i say the f-bomb if i say the
f-bomb we get de-monetized
which then hurts us in the algorithm so
you don't see these videos i mean
there's just so much
drivel in there the amount of good that
america has done the amount
of good that capitalism has done so that
all of us could rise
and have more and be freer and all those
things and the twisted way the new york
times which again is not a newspaper
it's it's leftist trash propaganda
um the way they want to turn young
people against their parents
look what you did by consuming with your
refrigerator
that you fed me with look what you did
with your american-made car
look what you did like they actually
want to turn us against the generations
before us that's part of what this thing
is by the way guys
that is by design it's not that they
just want to destroy the institutions of
the past
they need you to believe that the people
who came before you
literally the ones in your family who
raised you they need you to believe that
they were
evil too so that when they destroy the
family where else will you turn you will
turn
to them right you will turn to them boy
everything was so evil and my
family was part of it grandma with all
that frozen meat in the freezer what was
she
saving all that meat for she was cooking
it probably to feed you you idiot
um it's just endless but okay if you
think
that joe biden with his emergency powers
can uh save us well he's he's not sure
he can
even joey he promised to save us right
trump was the incompetent buffoon
but but here's joe uh just a day or two
ago
we have recently discovered in the final
days of the transition
and it wasn't until the final days we
got the kind of cooperation we needed
that once we arrived a vaccine program
is in worse shape
than we anticipated or expected a lot of
you
follow this and nobody is i mean
necessarily the press is the smartest
group of people in town
you you hone this stuff down clearly
i think you found the same thing even
before i took office i announced a new
vaccine
vaccination strategy which centers on
federal leadership and execution
for our whole country and that's why i
directed my covet team
to go to work immediately and how we
could step up the vaccination
efforts and the vaccinations
okay so there's a couple things there if
we watch further into the clip he's
talking about how this is going to last
for months and they're not exactly sure
what they have to do but the first part
of that
where he's saying that the plan that
they got from trump like it's worse than
they thought well he
ran on saying this guy has no plan it's
an evil plan he's killing people
you know he's not doing anything he's
incompetent and everything so the idea
that they walked in there and then they
looked down and they're like boy this is
really worse than the horrible thing
that we've been talking about it's so
much worse and he didn't carry the one
it's like come on it's like just come on
and then the reason that i really wanted
to show you that clip
was the way that he sucks up to the
media yeah the media
the press they're the smartest people in
town what town he's talking about dc now
i get it dc's filled
with a bunch of dingbats but but no the
press like
and also the idea that this guy would be
kissing the butt
of the press who kisses his butt all the
time that's a lot of butt kissing
and by the way speaking of butt kissing
now there's this thing coming out of
china we weren't even going to cover
this story today maybe i'll do it
tomorrow
more extensively but in china now
they've got people
taking not just the kova test up the
nose they're literally
putting it up the butt i kid you not
like that's coming next they're going to
literally have people
sticking q-tips up people's butts or
something like the
the never-ending cascade of epic
nonsense that we are putting up with
right now is truly
extraordinary and should be studied uh
for years to come
but speaking of lunacy and extraordinary
things to study for years to come
as i said california is going to get out
at least
partially out of lockdown which pretty
much everyone's been ignoring anyway
although it's destroyed all the small
businesses in this once great state
we're going to get out of it on friday
he gavin newsom who
uh recall gavin is it recall gavin.com
or recall gavin newsom can we can you
confirm that for me i want to send as
many people to the correct website i
believe it's just recall gavin.com
i'm not mistaken we'll get that in just
a sec um
gavin newsom who is our horrible
governor you guys all know how i feel
about him it's recallgavin2020.com
go check it out you actually have to
sign the recall by hand
last i heard they have about 1.3 million
signatures uh you need 1.5 but if you go
to the website
they'll help direct you to a place that
you can go and physically do it
you think that might be why he's also
keeping us locked down he doesn't want
people outside
able to sign the thing anyway uh he is
lifting the
stay-at-home order although something is
sort of
interesting about the numbers because we
actually have
50 percent less icu beds
than right now right now as i speak then
the day he implemented it i believe we
have a
fancy chart that the government has
provided
so that means that on the day that he
did this outdoor dining ban if i'm not
mistaken it was around december 7th or
so
that was when that woman sheila cool
i've talked about this a bunch
they had a meeting where they decided uh
by a 3-2 vote to shut all outdoor dining
and then she was the deciding vote and
then
literally went out to eat that night at
her favorite italian restaurant
in santa monica that's how ridiculously
moronic these people are
but on that very day when they closed
outdoor dining again
in los angeles which is basically 75 or
80 degrees and sunny every single day
although it did rain the other day so
that was nice
we had 2266
icu beds available well now flash
forward about six weeks
after we've locked down we've destroyed
destroyed more businesses
destroyed more lives we now have half of
that we have 1168 and now he's opening
the state do you get it do you get it
people
this man is a buffoon i would argue he's
a criminal and has people's lives
uh on his hands okay he's not a good man
uh but here's a little video
that'll make you smile critics are
saying this online that
um this decision today comes amidst a
recall campaign
comes amidst lawsuits and they say that
the timing on this is arbitrary and
convenient
based off of that i want to give you a
chance to respond to people that are
saying that yeah that's just complete
utter nonsense so let's just dispense
with that
fundamental foundationally nonsense so
that's just fundamental nonsense let's
just dispense with that brother
could he possibly seem like more of a
bad guy in a disney movie he is the bad
guy in the disney movie with the perfect
teeth
and the perfect slick back hair and the
fake tan and the whole thing and it
sounds like this
and people ask him legitimate questions
and i'm just gonna dispense with that
that man and also the blinking i think
we have to show that again that what's
going on with the blinking the blinking
and the touching
the blinking the blinking the blinking
is he sending us a message could we show
that again critics are
saying this online that this decision
today comes amidst
a recall campaign comes amidst lawsuits
and they say that the timing on this is
arbitrary and convenient
based off of that i want to give you a
chance to respond to people that are
saying that
yeah that's just complete utter nonsense
so let's just dispense with that
fundamental foundationally not
that's just fundamentally confusing
nonsense and dispense with
this is what they do all the time i mean
democrats have an incredible way of
doing this because the media lets them
off the hook
and i actually don't even mean that to
be partisan but it is a fact
this is what whenever joe biden gets
asked the question ah come on man and
then just walks away or when
when kamala harris gets confronted with
something what is she the evil cat
that's what they do and what does he do
there it's not it's not acknowledging it
that there is a
massive movement to have this
incompetent buffoon
recalled and i hope that i've had a
little something to do with it
uh he doesn't acknowledge his failures
right like what would a leader do if if
if we were really in this horrific
pandemic
and oh and which there is a pandemic i'm
not denying it and if we were seeing the
reality of watching our economy
destroyed and watching all of these
lives destroyed and
the depression that you guys know about
and suicides that are up which more and
more stories
keep leaking out and just think of the
way humanity has been fundamentally
changed in the last 11 months now also
uh joe biden wants us a hundred days to
mask
another 100 days now so we went from two
weeks to flatten the curve to 11 months
later we want 100 more days
of masking which 100 more days like yes
that's based in science
which just happened to be 100 days not
97 days not 103 days 100 days
if you mask up again i mean it's all
blithering idiocy but does that guy
seem like someone who the buck stops
with him does that guy seem
like somebody who feels any sense
of remorse or that maybe he made a
mistake along the way or something
or why doesn't he just come out there
and say you know what you know what guys
i understand that we have less than half
of the icu beds we did when we made that
that decision
six weeks ago maybe that was the wrong
decision and actually we've looked at
the numbers
and we don't think that further
destroying the entire economy
is worth the the cost right like we
don't think that that will save enough
people so we're going to have to reopen
and there's a little risk in life
wouldn't that be a little bit of an
honest thing to say
but we've elected people i suppose who
who are completely incapable
of being honest with us but at least we
have big tech that can be honest with us
that was a hell of a segue
uh twitter ladles and jellyspoons you
know that twitter.com site it is
it is a truly evil place online and if
you're not on twitter i wouldn't
recommend it it's where a bunch of
psychotic people
argue with genderless anime avatars all
day about string theory
um but they have launched something
called bird watch
to prevent dis information
let's look at the official video from
twitter support
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
well there you go people fear not the
age of disinformation is over
because hordes of genderless anime
he she avatars on twitter will now tell
you
what is the truth look they're basically
outsourcing truth to the mob
um they go further on to say we can show
this image that we have real quick about
what the qualifications are
if you want to get in the bird watch
program i thought the most
you know you have to have a verified
email verified phone number that's nice
actually because that will clean up a
little bit of it so i'll give credit
where credit is due
but i thought this one was interesting
bird watch is not available for
anyone who has violated twitter rules
now that's very interesting because you
know i often get messages
emails from twitter that my tweets have
been
reported and sometimes i think we've
shown one or two of them where
they'll say something like your this
tweet has been reported which my tweets
get reported all the time they only
they only send me the note on it if it's
like a big account that's reporting me
um so they'll say something like your
tweet has been reported
but we found out that it didn't violate
the laws of germany
so we're gonna leave it up i literally
got one a while ago that said that
my tweet didn't violate the laws of
pakistan so they're going to leave it up
so you see what's happening here as big
tech becomes
global and ubiquitous that literally
we're outsourcing truth to the mob
just like the whole bunch of people who
will tell you uh
that there aren't two genders and then
at the same time we're also being
beholden
to potentially the laws of other
countries that don't respect free speech
the way
we do here in the united states not that
we're doing a great job of it and
certainly
not that twitter's doing a great job of
it anyway it is a big
freaking mess but there's other ways to
enjoy life like traveling which i'm
about to do like eating good food which
i'm about to do and by connecting
with some like-minded people for some
interesting conversation which is
exactly what we're doing
at reubenreport.locals.com uh by the way
guys i just posted my interview this
morning with jordan belfort who
is the wolf of wall street if you saw
the phenomenal movie wolf of wall street
with uh leonardo dicaprio jordan belfort
is him it's based on his book his life
story
we actually grew up in in a very uh
similar area
know a lot of the same people although
he's a little older than me it's a great
interview he talks about the movie he
talks about business he talks about
inspiring people jail drugs the whole
thing you can watch part one
uh right now and of course it's ad free
at reubenport.locals.com
uh we're gonna do a live in person panel
on friday at the blaze with glenn beck
and a couple other people
and uh hey listen guys if you know
someone who could appreciate a different
viewpoint
be sure and check this video share this
video i should say
by clicking on that share arrow below
and oh and a special thanks to uh miss
tulsi gabbard who gave locals a shout
out on tucker carlson last night there's
a lot of good stuff happening here
people
all right stay sane and mask up
or die
you